là
oui
mais
pour le fondeur passé près
je vais bien
on
vous faites
ces piètres ce qu'est la nation
je l'espère
allez
et
il
enfin
suite
on a pu
c'est bon pour la veille
on a fléchi de
c'est évident que je -
il
dans les événements
plus
pour
m
je
on est forcément belle surprise
c'est bon
mes chers concitoyens mesdames et
messieurs à la suite du conseil de
défense sanitaire qui vient de s'achever
sous l'autorité du président de la
république je veux ce soir partager avec
vous un point de situation sur
l'évolution de la cinquième vague qui
frappe notre pays sur l'arrivée du
variant omicron qui nous menace à brève
échéance sur la campagne de vaccination
qui se déploie massivement et doit
encore s'amplifier sur les mesures enfin
que cette situation appelle temps pour
les fêtes de fin d'année que dans la
perspective du début d'année prochaine
la cinquième vague delta est là et bien
là en france comme dans l'ensemble de
l'europe elle continue de fortement nous
toucher avec plus de cinquante mille cas
par jour même si elle semble se
rapprocher de son point culminant pour
autant être se traduit déjà par des
tensions fortes sur nos structures
hospitalières qui ont quasiment tout
déclenché leur plan blanc à un moment où
d'autres pathologies sont très présentes
et où nos équipes soignantes sont
éprouvés et fatigué je me rends au près
d'elle très régulièrement pour leur
manifester le soutien inconditionnel
de la nation à cette situation s'ajoute
l'arrivée du variant au micro il se
diffuse à une vitesse fulgurante tour de
nous en europe avec un nombre de cas qui
double tous les deux à trois jours si
nous recensons déjà en france plusieurs
centaines de cas nous pensons que ce
variant va se diffuser très rapidement
au point de devenir dominant dès le
début de l'année 2022 comme il l'est
déjà royaume uni avec plus de 90 mille
cas recensés aujourd'hui c'est pour
cette raison que précisément nous avons
décidé de nouvelles mesures de
restriction et de contrôle pour les
personnes qui arriveront sur notre
territoire en provenance de
grande-bretagne à compter de demain nous
ne connaissons
encore pas tout de ce variant si sa
vitesse de propagation apparaît beaucoup
plus élevé il ne semble pas plus
dangereux que le variant delta et les
données dont nous disposons indiquent
qu'une couverture vaccinale complète
avec la dose de rappel nous protège bien
contre les formes graves de la maladie
il n'empêche qu'une nouvelle vague de
contaminations arrive alors même que
nous sommes déjà à un niveau très haut
et que je les dis nos hôpitaux sont déjà
sous très forte pression et le resteront
dans les semaines à venir pour mieux
nous préparer et nous protéger nous
devons donc prendre de nouvelles
dispositions
d'abord pour limiter au maximum les
risques de contamination à l'occasion
des fêtes de fin d'année car cette vague
survient au moment de noël un moment de
retrouvailles en famille tant attendu
par nos concitoyens après une année une
nouvelle fois éprouvante après 20 mois
de vie avec le virus les français en
connaissent les modes de transmission et
savent donc comment s'en protéger cela
passe bien entendu par le respect strict
des gestes barrières que vous connaissez
par coeur porter le masque éviter les
embrassades à aérer régulièrement les
lieux clos car plus vous aérer plus vous
chassez le virus cela passe par une
recommandation simple que notre conseil
scientifique rappellera dans un avis
publié demain plutôt qu'un nombre précis
6 8 ou 10 appuyons nous sur un principe
de bon sens - venez nombreux - on prend
de risques que ce soit à la maison dans
un restaurant une salle des fêtes où un
bar évitons les grandes fêtes les grands
rassemblements où les grandes idées dont
on a vu ces derniers jours par exemple
en norvège et au danemark
à quel point il pouvait créer des
clusters incontrôlable 2 diffusion
virale
nous faisons confiance à la prudence et
à l'esprit de responsabilité des
français il s'était déjà manifestée à
noël et au nouvel an dernier et avait
permis de déjouer les pronostics
par ailleurs et c'est un élément
fondamental pour limiter les risques
j'invite chacune et chacun vacciner ou
pas à se tester dans les heures
précédant ces moments de fête il peut
s'agir d'un test pcr d'un test
antigénique mais aussi tout simplement
d'un auto test très facile d'utilisation
pour ce qui concerne les grands
rassemblements et événements à
l'extérieur notamment le soir du 31
décembre les préfets interdirons les
regroupements sauvage la consommation
d'alcool sur la voie publique et
inviteront les municipalités à renoncer
à l'organisation de grands
rassemblements sur la voie publique
notamment les feux d'artifice ou les
concerts particulièrement quand ils se
traduisent par de fortes concentrations
et ne permettent ni distanciation ni
respect des gestes-barrières dans cet
esprit car un nul n'ignore que le mois
de janvier est celui consacré aux voeux
j'en appelle à la responsabilité de tous
pour trouver d'autres modalités que de
grands rassemblements et d'éviter en
tout état de cause les moments de
convivialité qui sont traditionnellement
attachés ces mesures viennent compléter
la fermeture des discothèques et
l'interdiction des soirées dansantes
dans les bars et les restaurants elles
sont difficiles je le comprends je
comprends la frustration de devoir se
limiter dans ces moments festifs mais
elles sont indispensables et nous les
devons à nos soignants depuis près de
deux ans ces derniers se battre pied à
pied contre le virus contre ces vagues
successives et ce sentiment d'un combat
sans fin nous leur devons beaucoup
nous leur devons d'abord notre
reconnaissance pour leur engagement
pendant les fêtes puisqu'ils
continueront sans relâche d'être sur le
pont à cet égard la rémunération des
heures supplémentaires réalisés à
l'hôpital sera multiplié par deux à
compter de lundi prochain et nous avons
demandé aux professionnels de ville de
se mobiliser pour assurer la permanence
des soins pendant cette période des
mesures seront également déployés pour
nos services d'urgence mais ce que nos
soignants attendent de nous c'est que
nous soyons prudents et surtout surtout
que nous nous vaccine ion car
aujourd'hui encore près de 6 millions de
personnes ne sont toujours pas vaccinées
ce n'est plus possible pour faire face
au virus delta comme ovarian omicron
notre meilleure arme notre seule arme en
réalité c'est la vaccination et la
vaccination avec trois doses désormais
les premières données scientifiques dont
nous disposons montrent qu'avec deux
doses le vaccin semble efficace à 70%
contre les formes graves de mikron ce
qui est déjà très important avec froides
aux ou équivalent cette barrière de
protection augmente fortement et dépasse
de nouveau les 90% aussi pour gagner
cette course de vitesse contre le
variant nous devons encore accéléré la
campagne de vaccination nous avons déjà
franchi ces derniers jours des records
avec par exemple plus de
950 milles injections réalisées
aujourd'hui un record plus de 17
millions de français sont pleinement
protégés et 25 le seront sans doute
d'ici la fin de l'année nous nous fixons
un objectif plus volontariste encore
pour les semaines à venir nous avons les
doses j'ai demandé au ministre des
solidarités et de la santé olivier
ferrand en concertation avec tous ceux
qui font cette campagne depuis de longs
mois élus professionnels de santé
sapeurs pompiers bénévoles étudiants
d'organiser ces prochains jours les
conditions de cette mobilisation
exceptionnelle et l'état mobilisera des
militaires formés à cet effet l'accès au
rappel sera en outre faciliter les
autorités scientifiques nationales et
européennes nous recommande d'anticiper
encore la possibilité de recevoir sa
dose de rappel et bien dès le 3 janvier
ce rappel sera possible dès que l'on
aura passé le délai de quatre mois par
rapport à la précédente injection et non
plus de cinq mois pour faire son rappel
alors que nous avons laissé du temps
beaucoup de temps à ces français qui
avaient des hésitations et des doutes
nous renforcerons en janvier
l'incitation à la vaccination
parce que il n'est pas admissible que le
refus de quelques millions de français
de se faire vacciner met en risque la
vie de tout un pays et entame le
quotidien d'une immense majorité de
français qui a joué le jeu depuis le
début de cette crise alors nous avons
décidé avec le président de la
république qu'un projet de loi sera
soumis au parlement début janvier
notamment pour transformer le pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale et durcir
les conditions de contrôle et de
sanction contre les faux passe désormais
seule la vaccination sera valable dans
le pass je procéderai en début de
semaine prochaine aux concertations
préalables sur ce projet ainsi que sur
toutes autres dispositions utiles pour
étendre au maximum la vaccination nous
assumons de faire peser la contrainte
sur les non vaccinés car les services de
soins critiques et de réanimation de nos
hôpitaux sont remplis pour l'essentiel
de personnes non vaccinées parallèlement
nous amplifierons lés démarches dit
d'aller vers en direction des
populations vaccinées qui ont pu passer
à côté de la vaccination par
méconnaissance ou parce qu'elles sont
traditionnellement les plus éloignés du
système de soins
vous l'avez compris même si nous sommes
face encore à une part d'inconnu sur les
effets de ce variant omicron le devoir
du gouvernement est d'anticiper et de
préparer le pays à cette nouvelle menace
ralentir et lycées la vague épidémique
omicron que les scientifiques nous
prédisent comme exponentielle sont deux
objectifs que nous devons nous fixer
pour limiter son impact
mes chers concitoyens mesdames et
messieurs je partage avec vous une
situation que nous aurions assurément
souhaité différentes je partage avec
vous qu'elle peut créer de la lassitude
mais je partage aussi avec vous et que
la vaccination nous permet de nous armer
encore et toujours face à cette nouvelle
menace sous réserve que nous soyons
ensemble le plus vigilant possible ces
prochaines semaines par rapport à
d'autres pays nous avons pris de
l'avancé dans la lutte contre le virus
nous devons la conserver et nous adapter
comme nous avons toujours su le faire à
l'évolution des variantes nous devons
tout faire pour éviter le recours aux
mesures contraignantes que nous avons
connu dans des phases antérieures je
sais combien cette pandémie peut
paraître sans fin pourtant grâce à la
vaccination massive
grâce à notre mobilisation collective
grâce au sens des responsabilités de
chacune et de chacun nous avons
progressé et appris à mieux vivre avec
le virus on va y arriver tous ensemble
je vous souhaite du fond du coeur malgré
ce contexte difficile mais que nous
aurons surmonté d'excellentes fêtes de
fin d'année merci beaucoup